a warning in this report from our
correspondent melania veselynovich does
contain some flash photography
scotland's last remaining coal power
plant consigned to history
the chimney at longanite station has
stood in fife for 50 years but today its
demolition signaled the end of an era
i think this is a really special day
it's a poignant day and it will no doubt
generate mixed emotions for people
who've worked in the site over 50 years
but it symbolizes that transition
scotland is making away from fossil
fuels to renewable low carbon sources of
energy it marks the definitive end of
coal in scotland which is such an
important moment
it was a symbolic act
scotland has been curl free since 2016
when longanite was closed by scottish
power a bit sad and emotional this time
just now here i've been here 13 years
and she just said it's the end of an era
but one of the biggest challenges was
making sure that communities that were
built around the fossil fuel industry
don't get left behind one of the things
that made me most proud of what we've
done here is that overwhelmingly all of
the people who wanted a new job we found
them a new career we helped people who
wanted to go and retire or to go and
find careers elsewhere and that's
massively important the people
communities the whole country feels like
it's going in this transition
longan had once generated nearly half of
scotland's power in its final act it
beamed warning stripes showing the rise
in temperature from 1850 to 2020
and a message urging a greener more
sustainable future milena vaseline rich
sky news